je suis à reims aujourd'hui on vous
emmène rencontré sébastien il est membre
du mouvement citoyen anti passe rens
bonjour sébastien bienvenus merci
beaucoup ne vouloir bien voulu répondre
à nos questions ça me fait plaisir de
vous recevoir aujourd'hui je vous emmène
si vous voulez
c'est vrai si on entend beaucoup parler
de propagande anti vague c'est ce que
vous vous définissez comme un anti
vaccins pas du tout en fait ça c'est
vraiment ce qui relève d'une forme
d'agitation médiatique à laquelle on ne
peut pas souscrire et pourtant vous
n'êtes pas vacciné aujourd'hui alors
voilà ça c'est une question typiquement
qui ne qui ne devrait jamais être posée
mais comme vous la poser avec beaucoup
de gentillesse je vais vous irez je vais
répondre avec beaucoup de gentillesse
non je ne suis pas vacciné mais en fait
ça ça relève de ce qu'on appelle le
secret médical
oui merci beaucoup
vous me disiez donc dans la voiture que
vous n'étiez pas vaccinés pourquoi est
ce que vous avez fait ce choix
aujourd'hui j'ai compris en tant que
citoyen éclairé que je n'étais pas
exposé aux formes graves aujourd'hui moi
je souscris tout à fait et bien à la
volonté pour certains d'aller se faire
vacciner d'ailleurs je veux bien utilisé
ce terme de façon à rester cohérent par
rapport à la caricature qui parfois est
fait sur vax anti-vaccins c'est pas le
sujet en fait voilà mais cette nuance
est nécessaire et c'était important de
le rappeler en france yann donc le pass
sanitaire bientôt le pass vaccinale qui
va être requis pour accéder à certains
certains établissements pour certains
loisirs comment aujourd'hui est ce que
vous vous organisez votre quotidien je
suis donc comme telle millions de
personnes dans une situation de
privation en fait il ya des pans entiers
de ma vie de citoyen qui n'existe plus
je me ré organiser autrement j'essaye de
d'orienter mes centres d'intérêt sur des
choses qui sont beaucoup plus on va dire
vrai je j'utilise ce mot qui paraît
peut-être un petit peu étonnant c'est à
dire qu'en fait j'ai retiré tout le
superflu et je me recentre sur
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est
l'humain au fait donc je ne suis pas
seule en france à avoir ce statut de
citoyens de seconde zone et donc
finalement nous nous retrouvons entre
citoyens de seconde zone je ne me suis
jamais autant senti vivent depuis qu'on
m'a privé de certaines de mes libertés
vous employer le terme citoyen de
seconde zone c'est un mot qui est assez
fort quand oui alors il a même vocation
à devenir encore plus fort dans les
semaines qui viennent puisque
l'expression citoyens de seconde zone
c'était à l'époque du pass sanitaire
avec le pass vaccinale qui vient d'être
acceptée en fait par l'assemblée
nationale même si on sait qu'il va y
avoir des allers retours qui sont
complètement fortuits puisque les choses
sont déjà écrites se passe vaccinale va
beaucoup plus loin donc là en fait nous
serons des hommes et des femmes en
déchéance de citoyenneté
un citoyen de seconde zone peut encore
prétendre avoir certains droits est
aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une réduction absolue
de ses droits au point d'être d'ailleurs
caricature est décriée et puis mis au
ban de la société dans quel état
d'esprit est ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes révolté
est ce que c'est de la colère est ce que
vous êtes inquiet aussi je suis inquiet
je suis révolté c'est tout ça en même
temps en fait c'est un espèce de deux
cocktails qui est très difficile à
contrôler parce que il y as en toile de
fond la colère et cette colère on sait
que c'est évidemment quelque chose qui
peut être dangereux je souhaite vraiment
faire cette parenthèse parce que moi je
n'ai pas compris à l'époque ce mouvement
d gilet jaune et maintenant je le
comprends rétroactivement
mais c'est quelque chose qui est cette
violence existe déjà depuis longtemps
voilà elle existe aujourd'hui évidemment
elle existait déjà à l'époque rien n'a
été réglé mais ce qui est encore plus
difficile pour ces personnes qui luttait
déjà à l'époque et qui sont fait
fracasser c'est que rien n'a été
débloqué pour eux et qu'aujourd'hui on
est en train de mettre sur la table des
milliards
et des milliards pour se faire tester
pour s'enfoncer les écouvillon dans le
nez on ne crée aucune richesse on ne
porte secours à aucune personne on le
redistribue aucune richesse on apporte
le soutien à aucune profession y compris
à celles qui ont plus besoin comme les
soignants parce que la question
l'hôpital est sur la table évidemment
donc voilà cette colère elle est encore
plus puissante que celle qu'ils ont vécu
à l'époque et on essaie aussi dans les
cortèges du samedi de canaliser tout
cela pour être audible